hey what's up everybody welcome to
stupid questions roast edition I'm here
with Nikki Glaser
Brian Moses coach T and AH Marrero a lot
of people don't know this we went to
grade school high school in college
together true and as I see you again
it's it's it breaks my heart I love you
so much Tom I appreciate that I really
do here we're gonna play a little game
it's a fill-in-the-blank game so bruce
willis is a lousy one French kisser and
I'll tell you why he does the thing with
his tongue the twirling thing that just
gets all mighty we actually you stop it
and relax and just rub the tug I would
love to roast Bruce Willis would you
yeah yes I don't like roasting now I
know but I just I'm a fan of Bruce
Willis oh I would like what's your
favorite Bruce Willis movie
look who's talking real 100% if I was
roasting Bruce Willis it's like those
eyes are like crystal blue I just get
like kind of getting lost in your eyes
oh thank you a problem I don't think he
makes eye contact oh yeah I've heard
that I've heard that like once that you
can't so I think that's why he just it's
not that he's rude or anything above it
he doesn't want people falling in love
with him that he can distract yeah the
work he needs no Stevie Wonder what do
you think his tombstone would say maybe
why are you staring at me like that
maybe it's it maybe it's say like look
who's not talking now you know cuz the
movie look who's talking all right
what would you say is your most roast a
bull attribute if I were roasting me I'd
go after the fact that I don't have an
ass okay yeah we just wrote yeah that
yeah I like I just have like a long back
I think that that's a good one
I don't need an ass to be honest with
you thank you for saying absolutely I
mean I sit in the war think about me I'm
so adorable you really are you know with
this this whole puppy face close the
eyes look that I'm going for
I don't know what they could possibly
say about me Brian Moses who is the
referee of roast battle do you have like
pre-battle pre roast battle pump up
music I'm a jazz guy interesting yeah
yeah a lot of Coltrane like I want unity
smooth because it's so vicious I'm
always listening to Taylor Swift because
she is like I like to think of myself as
the Taylor Swift of comedy a lot of
people have called me that because I've
asked them to I'm here with Coach Teague
the DJ whose stupid question what do you
think what's the what's the dumbest song
that you'd feel you've had to play
during a roast battle I have an
interesting rope because whenever the
comedians come out to battle I'm always
trying to make fun so like behind there
was that there's a guy and he had like a
short arm and so I played a song he just
kept repeating to put that hands up in
the air
and everyone's laughing cause I
literally can't cuz he's got like a
little miniature are
have you ever roasted someone so hard
that like you really felt guilty and uh
you just saw some happens to me and
they're like I feel guilty so main view
we roasted Ann Coulter last time and I
went really hard on her and it felt
great and I didn't have any regrets
about it so I never want to say anything
that's gonna make someone feel terrible
about who they are unless they're a
terrible person like Ann Coulter and
then it's like you need to know I didn't
have to hold back at all
have you ever roasted someone so hard
that you felt guilty afterwards you know
who Jack Palance is Jo she of course
city slickers he got mad at people I
heard Chevy Chase did too right but you
can't go like somebody would say
something there we go
you think you got the theme of this
whole thing it's a joke you know jack
talent he's dead now right he the dead
are having a tremendous Lal in his
career here's something because I don't
like to roast really because I don't
like to be mean
right and you're like a really nice guy
I could tell that but you're a part of
this roast battle show where people are
slamming people yeah so how do you well
how do you get into your place where you
can just be mean just for a little bit I
I love it cuz I don't consider it to be
me
okay I don't think anybody should ever
have power over you period so when
something actually agitates you it's
like that's a moment in your life and be
like why am I so uncomfortable with that
that was like some robot of Gandhi